Donald Trump is written never really
seemed to understand the opioid problem
in the United States and we've been
talking about the problem for a long
time and here in Massachusetts including
here in Boston and also on Cape Cod it's
an acutely bad problem and meanwhile
Donald Trump thought it would be a good
idea to appoint a 24 year old frat boy
to run his opioid problem fortunately
that kid resigned but it hasn't taken
Trump out of being clueless on the issue
so first of all it's been three months
since Trump said that he would be
dealing with the opioid crisis as a
public health emergency and it's true it
is a public health emergency but he
hasn't actually started dealing with it
he's done nothing about it
but we have some signs of life now from
the Trump administration on the issue of
opioid addiction except it's the exact
opposite signs of life that we would
want to see Donald Trump commented on
the opioid crisis during a speech in
Ohio this week and he says that he's
going to be handling the opioid crisis
as a law enforcement issue not as a
public health issue he said about the
epidemic that it has quote never been
worse people form blue-ribbon committees
they do everything they can and frankly
I have a different take on it my take is
you have to get really really tough
really mean with the drug pushers and
the drug dealers this is exactly the
wrong way to deal with it because we
know that much of the problem with the
opioid crisis is people who are
prescribed legal painkillers by a doctor
right often over prescribed and then
they become addicted through that legal
prescription their prescription runs out
they start buying painkillers from
people they know at first and then
eventually maybe from people on the
street and then they realize wait a
second the painkillers are way more
expensive than the heroin I'll just buy
the heroin and end up saving money and
of course we know how that ends up so
that this has to be dealt with as a
public health issue and yeah there are
dealers selling both painkillers and
heroin but the dealers don't create
man the system is creating demand here
and the root cause is not that there are
dealers selling pain pills and heroin
the dealers are selling pain pills and
heroin because there is demand and part
of the issue is that Trump is just so
ignorant about most things that he hears
about opioid addiction and he imagines
people probably black people in cities
selling heroin and the truth about the
opioid epidemic is that it's as much a
suburban rural white problem as it is an
urban problem and Trump's perspective is
just totally bogus and of course it's
subject to his racial stereotypes aren't
we learning anything from the war on
drugs where clearly this should be a
public health issue and not an issue
where we're gonna say how many people
can we incarcerate around what's going
on yeah and if the war on drugs had been
a success over the past 40 years maybe
he would have an argument here that you
just have to get stricter on law
enforcement hasn't worked we've seen
that it hasn't worked I actually have
have you had your wisdom teeth out Pat
yes did you get painkillers when you had
it done yeah they knocked me out uh just
like a strong ibuprofen okay not like
percocet right codon so I had my wisdom
teeth out when I think I was 20 or 22
and I had all four of them out three of
them were not impacted so that it was
just like pulling a tooth right I mean
very very little pain associated with it
one of them was impacted below the gum
so there was an incision made and there
were a couple of stitches I came out of
it and I was given 40 painkillers I
don't know if it was a percocet or you
know which one it was but it was an
opiate painkiller and I went home and as
the Jenner as the novocaine wore off
that one tooth started to hurt or where
the tooth used to be started to hurt and
I had the 40 painkiller so I took one of
them didn't really make me feel great
didn't like the way it made me feel and
it didn't really hurt that bad so the
next day I just took for Advil yeah
needed and then that the day after that
I took planning Riyadh ville and then -
and then that was it and ended up
tossing the thirty-nine pills that were
given to me under what circumstances was
40 pills the correct prescription for me
for two stitches for one impacted wisdom
tooth and we know that that's how a lot
of addictions start and
when you're talking about pain relief a
lot of people report just the same
amount of pain after taking percocet
first is like an ibuprofen or
over-the-counter drugs it's pretty
comparable it is in depending on what is
going on right I mean so number factors
not in not in every case but in firm it
for me it was effectively the same to
take the percocet or oxycontin codone
whatever it was and versus just taking
for Advil and it was it was a ludicrous
prescription to give me for that I still
have my wisdom teeth I can bring them in
if you want me to oh really yes
interesting please don't do it and never
mention it again